uh I just saw did in Paris just have a
new certification yeah it just went
diamond yeah crazy and it's crazy
because you know that was like a few
years before the streaming there so that
was like people really buying that song
that's that's like the difference in the
game now like I just feel like
it was like a little more earned back in
the day like I just seen ice spice how
long she's been out less than here she
got a billion streets like I'm like I
spiced it I gave us in a wild place I'll
be like I think she's out streaming like
almost everybody except like Bad Bunny
and Drake maybe that's that's incredible
you know whatever she did in her life to
get that blessing for sure but you know
just music Wise It's like wow this is
the era we in you know you gotta accept
it I guess I remember at your old house
in your studio you had like um you had
the Grammy and then you had there was
like a Michael Jordan photo or something
and then there was like um the canvas of
like when Jay and Kanye I think they
were doing in Paris I think it was that
that was that was right there it was a
parent it was a picture in Paris yeah
um it's crazy to think like how much
that record like kind of changes your
trajectory of like just hit boy like I
remember during that time there was like
you were you were like one of the young
producers around a good music My Guy
lifted from Phoenix and did mercy and I
remember he was just telling me all
these stories about like being in hotel
rooms like back to back to back with
like yourself everybody everybody
everybody
what's like one of the craziest like uh
stories you could tell about like just
those days like working with gay working
with the good guys it's a lot man
definitely like that uh trip I'm sure
lifted is talking about we had all went
to London one time and everybody was
there Sean push it two chains you know
obviously yay just being locked in I
remember it was so crowded in uh one of
the hotel rooms and everybody came in
because they was working on it was
either click or Mercy one of the two and
like Sean was sitting on the floor with
a mic like this like recording a hook
for one of them joints and I just I'll
never forget that Craig a was right here
change was in everybody was in there
just a room full of people and they just
was getting it done by any means like
right there
um obviously you and Kanye kind had I
would I wouldn't say a falling out but
definitely not the greatest times in
terms of your guys's relationship how is
it is it is there any relationship at
all these days
um I mean
I haven't uh talked to him since we I
did the easy join with game like but I
ain't got no issues with you my uh I
heard that because I just worked on I
don't want to say who project well I
worked on somebody project I heard they
played him a song like this is just a
few days ago somebody texted me like yo
bro play yeah your song and it was like
yo we need Hit Boy to pull up so I don't
know you know he's I hey I heard he's
cooking right now yeah I heard that too
I heard he is in the studio I heard so
I'm with him man for sure yeah I ain't
got no issues with yeah anybody I know
Freddie's working with him right now
there's a lot of them I've seen I heard
about that yeah a lot of Kanye he's got
shoulder pads you know what I'm saying
yeah ain't no ain't no shoes no shoes he
wearing the socks it's kind of crazy man
if anybody I don't even question it
though boy because I remember when the
early gay [__] the the clothing I was
like No One's Gonna wear this look man
we might all be in shoulder pads in like
six months you know that's funny I don't
know if I can take it there but I feel